في هذا المكان هو مدخل البوابه لكليه
مجتمع تدريب غزه او ما تسمى بالصناعه هذا
المكان الذي يعاني من اوضاع بيئيه صعبه
جدا تنتشر الامراض في هذا المكان بشكل
واضح وبشكل كبير
جدا معاناه كبيره حتى في داخل هذا المكان
الذي يتبع لوروا هذا المكان الذي يتبع
للاونروا
يعاني ال النازحون في هذا المكان بشكل
كبير جدا في الحصول على المياه هذه طوابير
للحصول على المياه ساعات طويله يصطف
المواطنون داخل هذا المكان للحصول على
جالون واحد من المياه هو ليس الوضع
المعيشي صعب على مستوى الكهرباء فقط لكن
ايضا على مستوى المياه ايضا اسفل هذا
المكان القمامه تتجمع في كل مكان بصراحه
حتى تكاد النظافه الموجوده في هذا المكان
حالتها صعبه جدا والكل يشتكي من انتشار
الامراض بشكل واضح جدا اضطرينا نعمل هيك
لانه في اداه مواصلات غير هذه ان نعرف
نعملها لانه لا في سلر ولا في وقود انه
نجيب سيارات شحوم تجينا على باب الدار تدب
لنا ميه صيرنا نروح من المحطه ونجيب
وعملنا في السياره الله رزقنا بهذه
وعملناها وضبطنا هلقيت نحنا بنجيب ميه
عشان ندي للاطفال الطرق المكسره هي انت
شايف العجال كيف مفسخ هي يمكن رابع كوشوك
اركبها عشان هذه من اول الحرب واحنا في
جباليه البلد كله دمار و وطينه وكله وزي
ما انت شايف الوضع يعني مش ما بنسمح ان
نتكلم زياده عن اللزوم طب المي ايش
طبيعتها اللي تش الميه ميه مالحه ووسخه
هيك انت شفتها ويعني عنده المرض اكلنا
والزبل هي اطلع الزبل القمامه كيف عندها
اكلتنا القمامه ولا واحد مطلع لنا والله
الحاله مش علي بس على كل الناس الناس ماتت
من الجوع يعني بدك تيجي تشتري طحين 35
شيكل حتى شعبك مش ما حد سائل علينا ه
مرميين احنا الميه ما فيش الاولاد صاروا
معهم جفاف سخونه فيش علاج فيش شيء ارحمونا
عن جد ننا مايتين على البطيء لا لاقيين
حفاضات للاولاد ولا لاقيين اكله ولا
لاقيين شوربه كل شيء غالي الكيلو العدسه
بالخمسه شيكل ب 20 شيكل هذه عيشه الناس مش
عايسه امراض
جلديه لا اله الا الله العلاج مش لاقين
لاولادنا ابن دول اللي فات البوه ورم في
رقبته مايش اجيب له العلاج ومش متوفر في
الصيدليات لمين اللي بصير هذا فينا حرام
حرام المجاري طافه داخله على ناس ه الناس
هتموت اللي مش هيموت من الحرب هيموت من
الامراض والله وحياه الله الاكل ما احنا
لاقينه ا طلعنا بالجلابيه نصكم هي اللي
طلعنا بها من
الدار يا حاج لمينا من الزباله وبنل المس
والله ما طلعت غير بهادي والله ايوه حا
ايوه اودي بناتي بقى لي شهر مش عارف
عايشين ولا ميتين والله والله ما عارف
عايشين ولا
200 انقطعت السبل بنا خايفه على الاطفال
حياتنا يرحمونا يدوروا علينا احنا شعب
منيل شعب منكوب ايش اللي عملناه في حياتنا
ايش اللي شافوه الاطفال وهال الاختياريه
وه واحنا كبار يعني ايش بدي اقول لك جسمي
ليل ونهار انا سخن زي النار الاطفال يشهد
الله عننا الاطفال كل يوم دوا اسهال عندهم
نزله معويه زي ما كنت اعرف الاسهال والنت
وايش بدك بتلاقوا
السخانه عايشنا الواقع الصعب في هذا
المكان الذي يعيشه النازحون لكن هذا
المكان كان اكبر مكان للتدريب المهني في
مدينه غزه الان اصبح الاكثر كثافه من
النازحين في هذا المكان من داخل منطقه
الصناعه اسماعيل الغول قناه الجزيره مدينه
غزه